friends and family will soon be knocking
on your door so you have to ask yourself
what are they going to see on your
floors and carpet if the answer is dirt
and old stains it is time to call in
Zerorez the sponsors of this segment and
I'm joined by Ben McKee and Doug McKee
from Zerorez on with some tips on how
you can make your holidays cleaner
welcome back you guys thanks good to see
you Mercedes you too now tell us what is
the number one thing you would recommend
to people that are going to be hosting
guests the biggest I mean our guests
come I don't know about your in-laws but
my in-laws come in they're looking at my
floors or looking out through my houses
so Zerorez is here to help and save the
day so as you got people coming in give
us a call we can get your place cleaned
up and smelling fresh and it's not just
carpets but let's talk about the carpets
for a minute because you guys have this
patented ZR technology and if people
don't know what it is it really is the
greatest way to clean your carpets tell
us a little bit about it so as you see I
understand you got more Clinic carpets
it's a traditional hot water extract
action but what we do on traditional is
we don't use any soaps harsh chemicals
or surfactants and what that does is it
allows your carpets to stay cleaner
longer you don't have any dirt
attracting residue left behind and
that's what causes the crunchy carpets
which we all hate and it just smells
fresh when we're done because there's no
chemical deodorizers being used and I'll
throw this into your carpets dry faster
too it's really really nice it's
incredible I mean we'll show you later
on but we clean with a basically a 300
horsepower vacuum our truck mounts
powered by the truck's engine of the van
now yeah we're going Doug we want to see
you work in and just some of the zero
rest technology in action it's pretty
amazing
um it's just this is my favorite part
this is the one swipe where you have
this dirty carpet and with one swipe
with only water right this is literally
the power of water and you can see right
away it's a night and day difference and
like you'd think like oh I get nervous
coming on TV to see this but every time
we're able to remove the dirt the grease
the grime that's in the carpet and it's
just hot water it's our ZR water and it
cleans great and it dries really fast
now we only have a couple of seconds
left but I have to talk about this too
air ducts air ducts are so important you
clean those too we do so get your whole
our whole approach is get your home
clean from top to bottom yeah improve
the indoor air quality of your home get
your ductwork clean and we could do that
at your home and at your business so
give us a call yeah they go to
businesses if you want to make sure that
your employees are happy and not walking
on carpet that looks like that I don't
know where you got that from but that is
a good point now you guys always bring a
special to the table what do you got
going on you do so our pre-holiday
special right now you can get three
rooms of carpet cleaning for only 119
Plus for the holiday season we're gonna
throw in a free family pass to
glittering lights down at the speedway
yeah that is such a fun time you guys
are giving us the gift of clean carpets
and the chance to experience glittering
lights thank you so much thank you to
Zerorez for sponsoring this segment call
them so they can get your home holiday
ready three rooms of carpet clean for
only 119 plus all three family pass to
glittering lights the drive-through
light display at the Las Vegas Motor
Speedway you can call them at that
number right there
702-840-333 or go online to
zerorezlasvegas.com for more information
minimums apply